étude les temps changent en Allemagne de
l'Est ce matin l'organe officiel du
parti neuillès Deutschland publie un
texte du chanteur Wolf birman réfugiés à
l'ouest un texte insultant contre Egon
kreems le numéro 1 est allemand un
famille commente toutefois le journal
mais enfin le plus important aujourd'hui
c'est quand même l'amnistie générale
décider pour ceux qui ont tenté de
s'enfuir ou qui se sont réellement
enfuis à l'ouest Amnesty également pour
les manifestants interpeller ces
derniers jours Hélène rise Acher
en Allemagne de l'Est et qui veulent
quitter le pays illégalement commettent
un délit de fuite de la République
passible de deux ans de prison c'est
dire l'importance de l'amnistie décidé
aujourd'hui par les dirigeants du pays 9
jours après l'arrivée au pouvoir des Gon
crans premier geste concret d'ouverture
elle concerne les Allemands de l'Est
emprisonnés après un départ raté et qui
seront libérés ils sont environ 4000 et
aussi tous les réfugiés qui ont réussi à
passer à l'Ouest et qui pourront sans
crainte de représailles revenir en RDA
est aussi accordée à tous les
manifestants arrêtés ces dernières
semaines sauf ceux qui se sont rendus
coupables de violence ce geste de
clémence du gouvernement a été accueilli
par l'opposition illégale nouveau forum
comme un véritable pas en avant le
premier signal que nous attendions
depuis si longtemps mais pour
l'opposition lamnistie ne suffit pas il
faut d'autres réformes en particulier
les communistes doivent partager le
pouvoir avec d'autres groupes politiques
hier soir malgré les appels à la
modération des dirigeants cent mille
personnes ont défilé dans les rues de
Drège pour réclamer la démocratie la
police n'est pas intervenue la ministère
d'aujourd'hui prouve
que le gouvernement cherche à donner une
réponse à la contestation populaire
toujours aussi massive une contestation
Kegon kreems le nouveau numéro 1 est
allemand cherche à désamorcer il doit se
rendre à Moscou la semaine prochaine le
réformateur hansmodrov chef du PC de
Drèze annoncé hier à la foule que
l'Allemagne de l'Est s'engage dans un
processus de transformation
révolutionnaire